[Musica]
chi sei tu disse il bruco
non era un bel principe di conversazione
alice rispose con qualche timidezza io
sono
davvero non lo saprei dire ora chi sono
so chi ero questa mattina quando mi sono
svegliata
ma da allora sono cambiata così tante
volte che non so più che sono
ma cosa mi stai contando disse
austeramente il bruco spiegati meglio
temo di non potermi spiegare meglio di
così disse alice
perché non sono più quella di prima
lo vedi lo vedi anche tu
io non vedo nulla
rispose il bruco
ma come non vedi nulla io non riesco più
a capire niente perché dopo esser
cambiata di statura tante volte in ogni
giorno non capisco più nulla
non è vero disse il bruco ma come non è
vero non l'hai mai sperimentato non
l'hai sperimentato ancora disse alice
ma quando ti trasformerà in crisalide
come accadrà un giorno e poi diventerai
farfalla certo che ti sembrerà un po
strano non credi
niente affatto
rispose il bruco beh allora a me sembra
molto strano replicò alice a te disse il
bruco con disprezzo chi sei tu
[Musica]
e questa domanda
ricondusse il discorso al principio
alice sentiva un po irritata dalle
brusche osservazioni del blu che disse
ma perché non cominci tu a dirmi chi sei
tu e perché
rispose il bruco era un'altra domanda
imbarazzante
alice non seppe trovare una buona
ragione però
si ferma un attimo e poi
fece per andarsene vieni qui la richiamò
il bruco o una cosa importante da dirti
non arrabbiarti è tutto qui
rispose alice no
e allora cominciò a guardarla in
silenzio
e poi gli disse
e così tu credi di essere cambiata
sì ho paura di sì rispose alice non
posso ricordarmi più le cose di una
volta sono cambiata si e questo mi fa
paura
non rimango più nella stessa statura
neanche per 10 minuti
non so più chi sono io
e tu chi sei
sì proprio tu tu tu tu
chi siete ora ora proprio qui a leverano
siamo a 3 dx ci sono io qui davanti a
voi che parlo chi siete ora ora dopo
aver ascoltato tutte le parole che hanno
detto ma soprattutto quello che è
accaduto qui cosa vi è accaduto a voi
ora
pensate no alla fine in un arco di tempo
esiste solo secondo me l'ora qui il qui
e ora
per me per noi che lavoriamo su che
stiamo su questo palco a raccontare le
storie le storie si fanno pezzo per
pezzo stando qui e ora è la prima cosa
che ti chiedono di fare stai qui è la
prima cosa che credo di fare agli attori
stai qui e ora ora qui
esiste solo ora in fondo il passato è
passato no è andato
eppure stiamo lì che ci incastriamo su
quello che è stato ma sei stato è stato
dopo domani il futuro boh
e mistero in qualche modo no il presente
è quello che abbiamo da gestire da
giocare da vivere
e
questo quello che accade qui è
interessante no cosa vedete da lì cosa
vedo io da qui fede belli
sede mascherati ma riesco a peter vi
trovate a a facciamo un gioco provate a
dire
provate provate a vedere a vedermi a
vedere tutto questo qua vedermi
provate a a pensare alla prima parola
che viene in mente per descrivermi per
dire chi sono
forze potete parlare anche come
baffo perfetto poi
come riccio poi ancora
maglietta
degli occhi pazzeschi poi ancora ancora
bello bene poi grazie poi
ora ora vi chiedo una cosa anche le
parole anche le parole che non sono
state dette quanto di questa parola che
avete scelto per descrivere me parla di
voi a parte quella con baffi che era una
donna forse ma forse sarebbero e dopo lo
so no
la ceretta
quanto delle parole che noi usiamo per
descrivere gli altri o per vedere il
mondo
parlano di noi
perché siamo noi a dirlo no
sono i nostri pensieri
che ci muovono
è però
vi è mai capitato
le parole io ho io sono innamorato delle
parole per me le parole sono sono quelle
che mi muovono continuamente e ho
imparato anche a usarle o provo a usarle
in un certo modo perché perché come
diceva una poetessa e le parole e le
uova vanno maneggiate con cura una volta
rotte sono impossibili da aggiustare
quindi avviate abbiate cura delle parole
allora questo queste parole fanno parte
di uno spettacolo già non ho detto
niente tutto quello che avevo deciso di
dire quindi buttiamo e di cambiamento
scusate non lo è il cambiamento non
prima al fuori mano detto a sei già
cambiando perché prendevo appunti volevo
aggiungere volevo e essi stiamo
lavorando sul cambiamento ho pensato se
lo cambio perché quello che accade qui
ora vediamo cosa ci dove ci porta questo
incontro il cambiamento incontro per me
è quello che accade tra tra tra di noi è
il teatro accade tra di noi non può
essere solo qui
e tra di noi
allora dicevo queste parole fanno parte
di uno spettacolo che ho fatto un po di
anni fa e lo stavo preparando proprio
qui alleveranno da un certo punto lo
dico a mia madre ora dico mamma che ne
pensi di questa fase ai fiumi ed è
proprio cuscino
figlio mio è proprio così
io ti guarda mamma e che è sì perché le
uova e le parole sono solo lame possono
fare male ma possono fare anche miracoli
ma quelli veri e i miracoli veri non
quelli
poi c'è stato un momento di silenzio e
poi dice però per fare una torta le uova
vanno rotte e c'ha ragione
io ho avuto la fortuna di vivere in
questo paese è di vivere in una famiglia
dove la trasformazione
la cosa era una cosa normale
loro fanno questo di mestiere
trasformano continuamente i materiali no
cucinano e quindi
ognuno di loro lo fa a modo proprio
infatti un'altra cosa che di sempre di
mia madre che mi faceva molto ridere era
che l'irap a cavallo in fugate della
mamma come di farcela viola è
no nera pack aule produrre lolo capiterò
però le rape insomma l'era una ricetta
pugliese le rape e patate come si può
tradurre
affogate affoga prof affogate
e allora no tutti quelli che lavorano
con mia madre dice no ai viola ma come
li fai tu è e meglio e lo fate come le
fai tu è quello il problema che tu
continui a fare quello che faccio io
devi fare quello che fai tu ed è vero e
proprio questo
a teatro la cosa più bella è che quando
lavoro con gli attori è dire non esiste
amleto
a me tu sei tu
quindi è semplicemente questo
l'attore non deve diventare qualcosa ma
sei quella cosa lì e anche noi non è che
dobbiamo diventare qualcosa diversa da
noi dobbiamo essere noi che ci muoviamo
da qualche parte non forza o comunque
come alice noi ci muoviamo continuamente
ci trasformiamo solo che a volte non lo
sentiamo lo capiamo o abbiamo paura di
sentirlo e questo subentra in questo
momento subentrano gli altri gli altri
ti permettono di capire dove stai
andando
aprire lo sguardo
respirare con gli occhi per poter vedere
un certo punto non bambina mentre
lavoravamo giocando il teatro ha detto
francesco a babbo detto papà perché loro
un po mi chiamavano un po erano piccoli
e francesco preciso ho capito una cosa
per guardare bassano gli occhi ma per
vedere serve il cuore io a quel punto
ho detto va bene bravo buffer io lo
vedevo fa più niente
è proprio così per vedere serve il cuore
serve il corpo
noi siamo corpo e questa è la cosa
interessante
noi ci muoviamo con questo che siamo e
per raccontare una storia
serve servono una serie di azioni e per
questo ci avete il foglietto no provate
ad aprirla adesso lo potete aprire
ma mettiamo la musica così li aiutiamo
facciamo un esperimento facciamo un
gioco che faccio a volte con con gli
attori no allora lo potete aprire e c'è
scritto che sei tu ma la domanda che
apre questo dirò chi sei tu allora io vi
chiedo una cosa provate ciave tanto
anche la penna no
oppure averlo pensato no scrivete lo
scrive the law perché serve proprio
allora provate a prendervi un tempo c'è
la musica
provate a scrivere tre verbi che parlano
di voi che vi caratterizzano tre verbi e
va bene ce l'avete forza forza ma non
parlare di voi però state tutto con voi
stessi
respirate
state un attimo con voi pensate a tre
verbi che parlano di voi
che un tempo ancora sto nel tempo qua
cielo che scorre davanti quindi non vi
prendete il vostro tempo
poi sono l'ultimo un po di tempo in più
[Musica]
a un'azione che racconta di voi
per esempio vuole dire sono una persona
allegra allora che faccio per essere
allego salto saltare e cantare
[Musica]
sente la musica può aiutare
ci siete
ce l'avete
si sono state la mano una scuola cela
dai ancora non ne dai forza forza che il
tempo passa
[Musica]
chi sei tu
ce l'avete dobbiamo averlo tutti è forza
forza che il tempo passa se no devo dire
un sacco di cose già siamo a 5 minuti o
forza ci siete
allora vi chiedo una croce l'avete dai
sì sì ok perfetto vi chiedo provate a
darlo alla persona accanto
dai forza ma tutto l'imbarazzo da non mi
imbarazzata e altre non vi preoccupate
sono tutte persone carine forza accanto
datelo scambiate vero ve lo siete
scambiato l'auto come si agitano vada
come si agitano perfetto ma subito
perché ho qualcosa
da te qualcosa di voi all'altro forza
ci siete la vede dato allora vi chiedo
questo ascoltatemi provate a leggere i
verbi degli altri provate a bene bene li
sta leggendo
allora adesso vi chiedo vi chiedo una
cosa li potete fare quei verbi
li potete agire
sì o no sì tu li puoi agire dimmi che
cosa c'è scritto
come
organizzare ben
organizzare
come a
dedicare un perfetto
rimpianti 16 fare tutti quindi tu
potresti essere lei
perché no si no
se voi lo potete fare
potete capire anche l'altro vero
questo per me per esempio empatia il
lavoro dell'attore è un lavoro che entra
in empatia entra nei panni dell'altro ma
come attraverso le azioni io posso
entrare nei panni dell'altro se capisco
l'azione che la muove che la muove nella
sua storia e così pure noi possiamo
entrare anche in empatia con delle
storie che sono molto lontani da noi a
volte noi attori dobbiamo entrare in
empatia con i personaggi di merda si può
dire merda hanno detto no dei personaggi
che non che non raccontano che non sono
quello che vuole
o
sanguinari terribili però quello è un
allenamento ma
l'empatia che è una parola ormai che
tutti dicono
è un muscolo è un muscolo da allenare ma
prima di tutto con noi stesse bisogna
allenare l'empatia con noi stessi a
entrare nei empatia ascoltarsi
ascoltare gli altri ascoltarsi perché
poi un'altra cosa empatia vuol dire per
me almeno vuol dire non per forza essere
in accordo con gli altri perché se sei
in accordo se in accordo che tu sport
sta a fa niente no
per me empatia vuol dire cantare una
canzone che non conosco
stare in una storia che non conosco
questo per me vuol dire entrare nei
panni dell'altro ed è molto più semplice
basta agire i panni dell'altro
qui
ora
non dopo non domani
c'è una frase no mena mena camionista
meno agli enti che è una frase che
pugliese che vuol dire magni sbrigati
sbrigativi che ora sta buttando il boom
che sta tirando il vento è un po come
dire cogli l'attimo no allora ogni tanto
questa frase mi ritorna
primo perché lo dice a mio papà ma lo
dicevano tanti altre persone di leverano
ma più che altro perché ho pensato
quante volte
ho aspettato dopo
non sono stato qui e ora no ho aspettato
il momento giusto sapendo che il momento
giusto solo quello che abbiamo adesso
qui
è solo questo il tempo che abbiamo a
disposizione non ne abbiamo un altro
melamina ramos tamil l'inte allora ho
pensato che voglio partire proprio da
qui da questo limite come dicevi prima
tu da questo cerchio voglio stare qui
e pensare che può bastare anche quello
che sono qui ora
e poi ho pensato che forse
il vento
posso essere io
possiamo essere noi
provate un po ci avete un po di atti ma
non
si può fare no possiamo essere vento
se lo facciamo tutti insieme possiamo
fare pure un uragano e allora buon vento
a tutti menamé che molto a me l'hai
detto
quasi ce l'ho fatta ciao